i'm gonna be covered in avocado by the
end of this but i don't even mind this
this is so good
hey hannah hi
so excited to be in the tasty bedroom
today so hannah describe to me your
dream breakfast my dream breakfast i
feel like is super los angeles it's
avocado toast
with poached eggs and a green smoothie
so the base of the avocado toast is your
bread and i love a nice hearty rustic
slice of bread i don't shy away from
carbs i love my carbs then you got your
avocado it's creamy it goes well with
any seasoning it's so versatile i mean
i'll just scoop them straight out of the
skin plane
it's like one of my favorite foods i
managed to buy a house while still
eating avocados so i i feel very blessed
and then poached eggs are just they're
so lovely it's very soft and it just
like i don't know it goes so well on
everything i like meals that hit every
food group or at least try to hit every
food group and i feel like that
breakfast is super complete and then
with a green smoothie that's just a
staple in my house because i have one of
the pickiest eaters on the planet so i'm
just always used to having a green
smoothie every day because that's how i
like shove vegetables in in my kids
oh my gosh
thank you
oh this is just
oh my gosh this is beautiful you did
avocado roses i feel like a princess
right now can i start yeah dig right in
is this what you're normally having for
breakfast i eat this for breakfast
almost never because most mornings
are so rushed in my house we're getting
four different people ready to go all
different places but i usually don't
even have breakfast my breakfast is
usually like five gulps of coffee maybe
some water if i'm
feeling like i have the extra time
hold on
oh wow
that was so good what are you making
your kids for breakfast for my kids they
love pancakes i can put anything in a
pancake and they'll eat it i recently
have tried
omitting sugar where i can from our food
so i make a lot of oatmeal that's just
plain and the kids do really like it and
then while they're eating that's when
i'm getting ready in the morning when
you're not rushed in the mornings do you
enjoy cooking i love cooking that's my
love language i love to cook for people
we just moved into our first home
and literally
having a kitchen to host in that's like
a nice sized kitchen has been everything
to me because i want to cook for people
i want to make all sorts of cool food
and and just bring everybody together
and show them that i love them
oh this is a good one do you have a
signature dish
i have a few signature dishes there was
one christmas that my mom
decided she was hosting and she didn't
want to do any traditional food so i
tried making chicken piccata and it
turned out incredible and i actually
don't have a recipe for it i just
swinged it and so i've been winging it
ever since but that's something that i'm
asked to make a lot i also love to bake
for everyone's birthday i'll bake them a
cake they get to choose whatever cake
they want and that's my treat to them is
there anything special you bake with
your family my mom's an excellent baker
so we used to always make these spritz
cookies they're actually my mom's dad's
recipe and it's this really really
buttery cookie and you use a cookie gun
to squirt them out that was just always
our
tradition for holidays when my grandpa
was still alive and it's something that
we continue is there a food you
absolutely could not live without
cheese and like i love artisan cheese
sometimes for my meals i'll just grab a
wedge of free and like pull chunks off
of it and eat it until i realize i've
had way too much
but it's just i can't quit it i love
cheese so much what is the craziest
thing you've ever eaten when i was in
mexico i had cricket and worm
taquitos it was fine until i got a leg
stuck in my tooth there was like a
cricket like stuck in my tooth and
that's when i could like feel it and
realize that there was a cricket in my
mouth but the rest of it tasted amazing
if you could describe yourself as any
food what would you be i'd say i'm ice
cream because i'm always cold and i'm
just always there for you you know you
had a bad day
call me
you want some comfort call me you want
to take me into bed and cuddle
call me don't
don't actually
so i'm going to ask you some rapid fire
questions about what makes a good
breakfast scrambled or fried scrambled
tea or coffee coffee apples or bananas
apples ew bananas are disgusting
orange or grapefruit juice orange one
final question
pancakes or waffles
pancakes thank you so much for sitting
down and having breakfast with us oh
this was
truly
one of the most tremendous breakfasts
i've ever had i'm ready to like take
this home with me and get into my bed
and finish it up this was amazing
i don't even care if my lipstick is all
over my face right now this is worth it
you guys want to buy it there's too much
for me to handle right now